an ex-borg moves to Boston a half
Klingon moves behind the camera a
Starfleet captain goes to prison where
did the cast of Star Trek Voyager end up
once they return from the far reaches of
the Galaxy
Kate Mulgrew wasn't the first choice to
play Captain Janeway in Star Trek
Voyager Academy Award nominee jean-vieve
Bujold was famously cast first but
filmed only a few scenes before quitting
the show during the series pilot today
it's difficult to imagine anyone else in
the world though it's hardly mulgrew's
only iconic TV series
following voyager's conclusion in 2001
Mulgrew took a few years off from acting
returning with a small role in the 2005
film perception after a guest appearance
on Law and Order Special Victims Unit
Mulgrew snagged a recurring role on the
black donnellies in 2007 and another in
the short-lived NBC medical drama Mercy
in 2009. her return to a main cast
however came in The Adult Swim series
ntsf SD SUV where she played an eye
patch wearing leader of an
anti-terrorism task force alongside
future Star Trek Star Rebecca Romaine
Mulgrew found a major career Resurgence
in 2013 starring in one of Netflix's
earliest forays into original
programming Orange is the New Black in
the series she stars as red an inmate at
a women's prison the role that would
earn her in Emmy nomination Mulgrew
returned to Star Trek in 2021 voicing
Catherine Janeway in the Animated Series
Star Trek prodigy
Captain Janeway I prefer vice admiral
Janeway sitting in the chair next to
Captain Janeway for seven seasons was
Robert Beltran as Commander chicote a
former member of the anti-federation
freedom fighting McKee though Beltran
counts his Heritage as Latino chicote
was the first Native American regular
character in the franchise but was sadly
underused following Voyager beltran's
work on the small screen was mostly
limited to guest appearances popping up
in episodes of CSI Miami and medium in
the 2000s while filling roles in movies
like fire Serpent and Manticore
beltran's first recurring part on TV
after Voyager was in the series big love
playing Jerry flute another Native
American character who has plans to
construct a casino on a reservation
over the next decade Beltran moved away
from acting with a sparse handful of
minor roles he revealed on Twitter that
he turned down a chance to play chicote
one more time in the Revival series Star
Trek Picard as he was unhappy with the
part they'd written for him nevertheless
Beltran did come back to join Kate
Mulgrew for Prodigy voicing chicote in
his triumphant return to the franchise
the series sees the character lost in
space and his former captain on a
mission to find him actor Tim Russ had
already made a few guest appearances in
the Star Trek franchise before joining
the main cast of Voyager in 1995 but
perhaps his most notable pre-trek role
was this one what about you guys
we ain't found
Russ became a fan favorite as the Vulcan
Lieutenant tubach after seven seasons
playing the stoic emotionless tuvak Russ
kept busy with a variety of different
roles mostly guest starring and popular
TV hits this included guest spots in
everything from ER and law Order
Criminal Intent to episodes of Hannah
Montana and Without a Trace in a
multi-episode appearance on the hit soap
General Hospital that same year Russ
joined the main cast of the Christina
Applegate comedy Samantha Who and later
began working in video games providing
Voice work for Wolfenstein 2 The New
Colossus and others since then Russ has
kept busy with countless roles in a huge
variety of other TV shows more recently
Russ turned up in an episode of Seth
MacFarlane Star Trek homage the Orville
and in 2023 voiced lucious fox in the
animated film Batman the Doom that came
to Gotham on Voyager the role of chief
engineer was filled by the half Klingon
half-human bolana Taurus played by
Roxanne Dawson starting out as a McKee
Rebel she eventually becomes one of the
most important members of the crew as
well as a wife and mother following her
run on the series Dawson had just a
handful of on-screen roles which
included single episodes of the closer
and Without a Trace that's because like
her franchise cohort Jonathan Frakes
Dawson moved behind the camera to become
a full-time director
getting your start overseeing episodes
of Voyager Dawson moved on to helm
entries of the Star Trek spin-off
Enterprise before broadening to other
shows since 2005 Dawson has directed
episodes of some of the biggest hits on
TV including lost and the OC in 2006.
eight episodes of Cold Case and a trio
of Heroes episodes among her most
notable shows might be the David Simon
HBO series Treme in 2011 Hell on Wheels
with future Starship Captain Anson Mount
and Deep Space Nine engineer calmini and
modern masterpieces like Bates Motel the
Americans and this is us her most recent
work saw her return to sci-fi helming
two episodes of the Apple TV series
Foundation despite perpetually remaining
a low-level Ensign Harry Kim played by
Garrett Wang often played a crucial role
in defeating many of the enemies the
crew would face in the Delta quadrant
when Voyager left TV Wang bounced around
in smaller roles he's continued
embracing his role as Ensign Kim by
appearing at many fan conventions where
he found an entirely new calling
beginning in 2010 Kim embarked on a
career as an event moderator serving as
the Master of Ceremonies at that Year's
fedcon a science fiction Convention held
in Germany later he was the Trek track
director at the celebrated Dragon Con
held annually in Atlanta Georgia
over the course of his new career Wang
has held moderating duties at hosted
panels and events at Major pop culture
conventions in Montreal Edmonton Phoenix
and Denver according to Wang his biggest
role as a moderator came at the Calgary
comic and Entertainment Expo in 2012
where he interviewed the legendary Stan
Lee in 2020 Wang joined forces with
co-star Robert Duncan McNeil to launch
the Delta Flyers a podcast that
discusses classic episodes of Voyager
Robert Duncan McNeil guest starred in an
episode of Star Trek the Next Generation
as a Hotshot pilot who broke the rules
and wound up booted from Starfleet so
when producers developed a similar
character they brought in McNeil to play
him resulting in Brash Cavalier Helm
officer Tom Paris after Voyager ended
McNeil starred in an episode of The
Outer Limits Revival and a few more
small roles however like Roxanne Dawson
McNeil left acting not long after the
series ended to become a director and
producer starting with four episodes of
Star Trek Enterprise into the 2000s
McNeil helmed episodes of Dawson's Creek
and one tree hill before becoming an
executive producer on the action comedy
series Chuck where he'd direct 21
episodes across its Five Seasons from
there McNiel went on to sit behind the
camera for installments of other shows
like the Orville and Suits since the
2010s McNeil has served as an executive
producer on further shows that included
the gifted the Disney plus reboot of
Turner and Hooch and the Sci-Fi series
resident alien in addition to hosting
the Delta Flyers podcast with co-star
Garrett Wang McNeil came back to Star
Trek in 2022 when he voiced the
character of Tom Paris on the animated
comedy Star Trek lower decks This Is How
We Kick Ass in the Delta quadrant
another actor to appear on Star Trek
before taking a leading role on Voyager
Ethan Phillips played the quirky alien
Chef neelix for all seven seasons of the
show's run a well-established TV veteran
his roles prior had included dramas like
NYPD Blue and family hits like Doogie
Hauser MD after his role on Voyager he
went back to his former career as a
character actor in The ensuing years
philbs could be seen all over the dial
and Beyond with parts and shows like
Touched by an Angel and eight simple
rules and even a guest starring role in
an episode of Enterprise in 2002 later
he did a three episode run on Boston
Legal a legal drama from David E Kelly
starring Star Trek Legend William
Shatner in Deep Space Nine Alum Renee
aberge Noir one of his episodes just
happened to also feature deep space
Nine's Armin shimmerman some of the
biggest shows he's found work on during
the 2010s include Better Call Saul and a
recurring role in Lena Dunham's girls
he's also had roles in major movies
showing up in inside Llewellyn Davis and
The Purge election year though he hasn't
come back to Star Trek Phillips did
return to sci-fi in 2020 joining the
main cast of the HBO space comedy Avenue
5. though she didn't arrive on Voyager
until season four Jerry Ryan arguably
became the series biggest star joining
the cast as a former board drone named
seven of nine it proved to be just what
the series needed and a career-defining
role for Ryan one of the few cast
members of Voyager to para lay her role
into bigger success Ryan immediately
joined the David E Kelly drama Boston
Public after the series ended in 2006
she secured another starring role in the
James Woods series shark smaller
recurring roles came after including
multi-episode stints on Law and Order
SVU Two and a Half Men and leverage
before Ryan returned to a main cast with
her co-starring role in Body of Proof in
2011. more recurring roles over the
years LED right up to her return to Star
Trek Picard in 2020 returning to the
role of seven of nine she supported
series lead Patrick Stewart by appearing
in all three seasons and rumor has it
she may even star in a spin-off
joining the crew of Voyager was Cass a
young alien woman with mild telepathic
powers and a nine-year lifespan played
by Jennifer Lee
unfortunately her character never quite
seemed to fit and in season 4 lean was
written out to make way for Jerry Ryan
as seven of nine
leaving the Series in 1997 lean's career
stalled in front of the camera though
she did play a role in American History
X alongside Star Trek Deep Space Nine
Star Avery Brooks however most of her
subsequent work came in animation with
Voice work in Superman the animated
series where she played inza the wife of
Dr Fate and a starring role as agent l
in Men In Black the series lean pretty
much left acting shortly after that she
married filmmaker Phil Wong and started
a family but has faced personal problems
along the way while struggling to deal
with her mental health lean was arrested
in 2015 for indecent exposure and again
in 2018 for driving without a license
actor Robert picardo already known for
antagonistic roles in Gremlins 2 and
Inner Space starred on Voyager as the
doctor the nameless holographic chief
medical officer whose program was left
running far longer than it was designed
to
known for his offbeat humor and
cantankerous attitude he was played to
Perfection by picardo and it would
become the actor's signature role though
his film history has weird aliens and
monsters is Iconic as well
listen I watch four episodes of laughing
before I figured out why the little
hairy kid never spoke
still even after leaving sickbay as the
doctor picardo had a healthy career
moving quickly into a role in the Lion's
Den in 2003 a year later he joined
another iconic sci-fi franchise when he
secured a recurring part in Stargate
SG-1 as Richard Woolsey a grumpy U.S
official who opposed the Stargate
program
following a string of appearances on the
flagship series picardo joined the main
cast of Stargate Atlantis in 2006. a few
years later picardo had another repeat
role this time as Jason Cooper on The
Mentalist and he later enjoyed a stint
on the Apple TV Plus drama Dickinson in
2023 the actor made a guest appearance
on the Quantum Leap Revival playing Dr
Woolsey whose name is a clear tribute to
his two biggest TV roles
late in season six of Voyager a
storyline saw the ship rescue a stranded
vessel commanded by a group of wayward
bored children at the conclusion of the
story four young drones joined the crew
becoming a surrogate family of sorts to
Seven of Nine the eldest of them is
ichib a teenager played by actor Manu
interim who went on to make 11
appearances across the final two seasons
of the show when Voyager ended in 2001
inter-rami continued acting with his
largest role coming in One Tree Hill
where he played Billy a local drug
dealer in a recurring role in 2012.
further projects were mostly Independent
films like 5th passenger in 2017
alongside a number of other Star Trek
stars and the 2019 Western Hell On the
Border in 2017 interiming came under
Fire for criticizing fellow Star Trek
actor Anthony Rapp who'd made
accusations of sexual assault against
Kevin Spacey a few years later fans
speculated those comments may have been
why he wasn't asked to return to the
role of Egypt in Picard with a new actor
playing the part in a scene that killed
off the character
foreign
[Music]